c'est la grand-messe des militants des
stratèges et des politiciens
conservateurs d'un bout de talent du
pays le groupe Canada strong and free
tenait sa conférence annuelle à Ottawa
la semaine dernière avec des invités
comme la première ministre Alberton
Daniel Smith le chef du pcq et l'ex
Premier ministre Steven Harper le but
faire le point sur l'état du mouvement
conservateur au Canada
[Musique]
eridium bonjour merci d'être avec nous
bonjour vous êtes vous étiez à la
conférence conservatrice Canada strong
and free comment se porte le mouvement
conservateur au Canada je pense qu'il va
très bien la preuve c'est qu'un
nous-mêmes au Québec on est parti de 1
pour définir 13 pour cent dans la
dernière année on a une croissance très
impressionnante je regarde aussi les
récents sondages on regarde la montée
depuis à poilieve et j'ai confiance
aussi pour les élections fédérales à
venir donc je pense qu'il y a un nouveau
conservateur puis ce qui est un peu
différent c'est que notre électorat de
plus en plus jeune historiquement
nécessaire les conservateurs aux
personnes beaucoup plus âgées 65 ans
plus maintenant c'est le contraire de
notre électorat il est plus jeune que
celui de nos adversaires et je pense
qu'un renouveau conservateur qu'on peut
poignée présentement c'est pas juste au
Canada au Québec également on a beaucoup
parlé durant la fin de semaine de de
conservatif mais populiste monsieur un
peu dans son discours
essayer de faire la de faire de faire la
preuve que populiste n'était pas
nécessairement négatif quand on
l'associe au moment conservateur et
quelle est la différence entre les deux
pourquoi exactement le débat de
populisme la droite pas le monopole du
populisme mais non-masso-québec par
exemple une policière très à gauche qui
quant à moi est populiste est très
populaire dans sa façon de s'exprimer ça
bien sa façon d'être je pense qu'elle a
un discours très populiste les exemples
qu'elle utilise dans ses discours moi
pour moi de populiste mais pourquoi il y
a un élément péjoratif la popularis
quand on l'association conservateur sous
forme d'élitisme de snobisme pour moi
c'est comme si c'est comme ça je le
perçois là parce que pour moi être
populiste c'est justement c'est moi je
sens politique pour faire du populisme
dans le sens où je veux que mes parents
par exemple qui ont moins de scolarité
mais quand je parle de politique
publique ils comprennent des fois je
parle ils sont cas de se forger une
opinion à partir du discours qu'on a
c'est pas juste des cassettes c'est pas
juste des gros mots pour exclure une
partie de la population je pense qu'il y
a de ça dans le populisme également puis
au Canada c'est si on a historiquement
plus associé la droite au populisme mais
c'est pas c'est pas une pari par
définition il y a pas de lien
nécessairement entre la gauche de la
droite versus le populisme vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure les les ça va bien
les chiffres au chiffre de la dernière
élections sont bien les chiffres des
derniers sondages sont moins bons par
exemple vous avez perdu 4 points selon
léger
comment garder comment vous faites pour
conserver votre partie dans la tête des
électeurs à l'esprit des électeurs
québécois c'est le défi qui nous attend
parce que c'est clair que le fait que on
n'a pas dilué à l'Assemblée nationale
même son œil pratiquement le même nombre
de votes que les libéraux les solidaires
ou les pékistes fait en sorte qu'on a
beaucoup moins de visibilité donc
beaucoup moins d'opportunités de faire
valoir nos opinions nos idées c'est un
gros gros défi il va falloir le faire on
le fait avant l'élection il va falloir
le refaire au cours des quatre
prochaines années puis on va continuer à
revendiquer évidemment pour vous c'est
d'aller chercher quelqu'un d'aller
chercher un élu mais de l'année comme
vous l'avez fait la dernière fois ça
c'est un des éléments mais il va falloir
aussi sortir ce qui se passe à
l'Assemblée nationale c'est une bulle
c'est nous le but c'est de faire du
terrain d'aller dans les régions faire
les tourner en train en contact les gens
avec les médias locaux avec les gens
avec les militants sur la base c'est sûr
que je vois tout de suite faire beaucoup
beaucoup de kilomètres au cours des
trois prochaines années et demi pourquoi
les conservateurs fédéraux parce que
évidemment la prochaine élection ça va
être élection fédérale présumée au
Québec pourquoi les conservateurs
fédéraux semblent bien aller un peu
partout au pays dans l'Ouest beaucoup en
mieux pas tant au Québec je pense que
Pierre pelliet va un problème de
visibilité au Québec dans le sens où on
le connaît encore trop peu moi j'ai très
confiance pour la prochaine élection
fédérale parce que c'est un gars d'abord
qui s'exprime dans un français excellent
et je pense que la prochaine élection le
fait qu'il va avoir une campagne voir
une opportunité de se faire voir sans
filtre puis les Québécois vont en
prendre à le connaître je suis convaincu
qu'il va avoir une montée le lien entre
la popularité ou l'impopularité des
conservateurs fédéraux au Québec et
votre partie il y en a mais c'est sûr
que historiquement ça existait pas parce
qu'on sortait du Québec parce qu'il y en
avait pas mais on le voit partout
ailleurs au Canada c'est des vases
communicants puis d'ailleurs il y avait
un sondage de récemment dans l'actualité
qui démontre que les trois quarts de nos
électeurs appuient les conservateurs
depuis un polieve la région où on a fait
le loin les meilleurs scores dans la
région de Québec là où les conservateurs
ont déjà des députés puis des assises
depuis longtemps donc c'est même si on
n'a pas de lien organique c'est évident
qu'on est des vases communicants et je
pense que c'est pour c'est une des
raisons d'ailleurs pourquoi moi au début
quand je suis arrivé comme chef du parti
il y avait des gens qui disait faut
changer le nom du parti moi je suis pas
d'accord tout je pense que conservateur
ça veut déjà dire quelque chose dans
l'esprit des gens c'est un parti qui est
au centre droit politiquement si j'ai
fait de campagne avec la décaque Mario
Dumont une certaine époque on faisait du
porte-à-porte puis après 10 ans
d'existence du parti le monde pensait
qu'à véhicule ça voulait dire à
l'aéroport de Québec c'est son père
c'est très difficile de développer une
marque de commerce politique et le mot
conservateur ici quelque chose puis il
faut juste s'assurer qu'il retrouve ses
belles heures de gloire parce qu'au
Québec on a quand même 8 Premier
ministre conservateurs ça va mieux aller
pour Pierre polie quand tu vas être sur
le terrain mais on avait ça aussi des
renauto on avait dit ça d'être riches
avant lui monsieur un peu informé un
véritable il y a de la difficulté à
percer au Québec je pense que Pierre
Ollier avait plus compatible bien
connaître le pire c'est un ami depuis
une vingtaine d'années c'est un gars qui
est plus compatible qui s'exprime
beaucoup mieux en français qui est pas
un conservateur social je pense qu'il y
a des trucs qui ont qui ont eu des
problèmes historiquement au Québec pour
les conservateurs ou puis apollia va
pouvoir tirer son épingle du jeu vous
avez pris la parole à la conférence la
semaine de la semaine dernière pour pour
parler d'idiot carbure vous avez défendu
le développement des hydrocarbures c'est
pas qui est particulièrement populaire
au Québec comment vous faites pour
rallier les Québécois derrière et quand
on dit que c'est pas particulièrement
populaire je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret prenons le projet parce que
c'est un des gros projets au niveau des
hydrocarbures GNL Québec ok le gaz
naturel liquéfié ou saigner lac
Saint-Jean la population là-bas est très
favorable au projet et pourtant le
gouvernement qui avait promis d'aller de
l'avant avec le projet a reculé je pense
que monsieur Legault comme beaucoup
d'autres politiciens malheureusement il
y a écouté des chroniqueurs plutôt que
d'écouter les électeurs les Québécois
ils veulent travailler ils veulent
développer ils comprennent que
d'importer 100% de notre gaz puis notre
pétrole au Québec c'est pas
économiquement rentable c'est pas
environnementalement
positifs parce que parce que elle est là
elles sont abondantes et dans le
contexte actuel quand quand on oriente
une politique de lutte contre les
changements climatiques ça joue un rôle
important dans tout ça est-ce que ça ça
vient pas miner un peu le message au
contraire je trouve que ça le bonifie
moi je suis dessus qui croit pas contre
le développement de nos barrages pour la
diversité énergétique au Québec une
force stratégique on voit que la guerre
en Ukraine une force stratégique le site
d'être riche en ressources au Québec là
on est maintenant 100% dépendant au
niveau de nos hydrocarbures de
l'étranger moi je veux que les Québécois
deviennent autonomes en matière
énergétique y compris au niveau de leurs
hydrocarbures et c'est faisable on a
encore pour 50 ans de croissance de
demande au niveau du gaz naturel que
quand les gens disent une énergie du
passé au contraire l'Europe est en train
de dire c'est une énergie verte une
énergie transition m'emmener il faut il
faut aller de l'avant il faut arrêter là
de de de d'avoir peur des lobés
environnementaux la réalité c'est que
quand on importe nos hydrocarbures de
l'extérieur ils sont plus polluants que
si on avait le courage de creuser sous
nos pieds de faire travailler notre
monde puis de consommer notre propre gaz
notre propre
projet au conservateur fédéraux entre
autres dans les dernières années de
faire peu de place dans leur programme
électoral à toutes les questions
environnementales est-ce que c'est une
erreur est-ce que est-ce que et comment
on peut concilier les deux visions c'est
ça qui faisait gagner des élections
monsieur le goût serait pas premier
ministre du Québec deux dernières
campagnes c'était pas sa force le volant
environnementale si je me souviens bien
même en 2018 il y avait rien dit à ce
sujet -là moi je pense que les dans
surtout dans le contexte actuel avec
l'économie qui est en période de prix
récession ou peut-être en tout cas
d'inflation la préoccupation des
Québécois présentement davantage
économique et je pense que c'est
là-dessus que les Québécois se font leur
opinion politique puisse là-dessus qui
vont voter aux élections fédérales
également
ça a été un grand plaisir merci à vous